hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast analytical method to
measure empty and full aad particles
presented by Christine but that PhD head
of analytical development Janet on we
are excited to bring you this
educational webcast
presented by lab roots and sponsored by
ethnic culture life sciences Becton
cultured life sciences delivers
innovative entrusted scientific
solutions across the globe for
laboratory customers in a wide variety
of settings universities government
biotechnology and pharmaceutical
companies hospitals and commercial
laboratories for more information about
our sponsor please visit Beckman comm
backslash home I'm julissa maratha
blabbers and I'll be your moderator for
today's event before we begin I would
like to remind everyone that this
student is interactive we encourage you
to participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation just click
on the green Q&A button located in the
lower left of the presentation window
and type your question into the box that
appears on the screen we'll answer as
many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation also please
notice that you will be viewing the
presentation in the slide window to
enlarge the window just click on the
screen icon located on the lower right
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation please click on the
support button at the top right of the
presentation window or use the Q&A
button to let us know that you're having
a problem now I'd like to introduce dr.
Christine Levesque dr. Levesque joined
JUnit on in 1997 and currently heads the
analytical development department she is
responsible for developing bio assays
and setting up advanced analytical tools
used for characterization and in release
in process testing of gene therapy
products at early stage development for
dr. lebecq's full biography please visit
lavage calm please join me in welcoming
dr. Christine Levesque I will now turn
the presentation over to her
Thank You Julie for this and solution
and for giving the opportunity to
protect our development regarding the
unethical classification technology for
ad vectors so first of all I would like
just to show you all the different parts
of the presentation and we made an
introduction of genital after that I
will introduce the process manufacturing
and the quality control of gene therapy
product and especially for ad vectors
and we make the after that present the
principle of analytical cuts
investigation and the proof of the
concept and the qualification of the
method for composition of empty and full
AG particles and in the land sponsor
will present some application of 480
particles so first of all Jainism has
been created in 1990 by years a
franchise decision of muscular dystrophy
is formed by the I am the French the
French a decision ginetto is an
integrate our and the center it's a
nonprofit organization we are currently
approximatively 200 people a researcher
technician engineer initiative persons
our mission is to design and develop
gene therapy product for Harveys we
ensuring the translational development
for from research up to clinical
validation genital is developing 34 how
genetic disease no mascara disorders
immune deficient eye and is a disease
our platform is based on AV and Lahti
virus vectors we are currently
sponsoring several gene therapy projects
that are which can cut RIA and we also
involve in several other project for
avian wanted
laterz in political and research stage
for no muscular and giver and eyes as a
the product that enthalpy product is
based on AV vectors I will present you
the profound difference process we have
been developed and used in a genital
first it's the most common production
process it's based on one of the most
common process is the ice for production
of small Lots is to transect at the on
cell line human cell line with three
different let's meet one for coding for
the transgene the 200 for the red and
cat and for the other one for the
adenovirus exterior function this
process we commonly use for producing a
via to research grade but in some case
for GMP lots at a small scale because we
will get like 24 can make like a Z scale
at 24 cell factory giving you around 25
litres of birth product so this process
has limited capacity is flexible fat
implements but limited capacity and the
cost is elevated a lot so for that we
have another process in parallel which
is birth instead of using other human
cells we use suspensions human cell line
and the transition is is base is done in
via writer and the current cell is two
other data in this possible bio writer
so this process can give you more
product button has also limited capacity
to 200 liters and it costs also a lot
for the batteries because we need to use
plasmid GMP source and for a large
campus production instead of using this
process we use another process
which is based on the baculovirus
process and we use it while baculovirus
expression system and you need for that
one baculovirus coating for the red band
cut off your oxygen necessary for making
the a vapor and the other one is cutting
for the torsion which you infect the
insect insect insect cells sf9 in now
the bio writers and the current set
scale is 200 meters in disposable bio
writers so this process has the capacity
DT to be scalable you need to the
implementation is slow because you need
to generate the baculovirus bank but the
cause is where is a smaller compared to
to the other process if you need to make
high number of lot a lot of Ag Victor's
after that I will present just as a four
on this slide down protests as a
dumpling process for a clarification of
a V so the four it's a for a different
measure stage so from the Alice you make
a clarification of the RV's you purify
the elevators on human chromatography
and you make after that and it's half of
three impartation concentration and
change and make your a V in the
formulation therefore just to obtain the
drug substance and in the Lance time to
make a painful patient and you make the
feelin change to obtain the drug the
drug product the AV production Archana
tone is based on these three different
process in transition in cell Factory in
cell Factory in transition in
Biosciences functioned or using the
baculovirus system we use this different
process depending of course of
also the require of the yield of the
product depending also of the needs of
the vector for making your fingers free
yarn and further need of the vector for
the massage anticipations
so this so and process is useful AV to a
v8 and a v90 type and these four
different clinical projects after that
after the production the quality of the
product will be iterated and the design
of the quality control package is based
on the guidance unless they require for
product release testing and for the
characterization of the product the
quality of the ad product is can be
divided in three different groups the
first one is a strand and those and it's
the viral genome titles of each divers
infectious title the activity and the
potency of your papers the second one is
making the characterization the identity
of the vapors in them of the DNA genome
in them of the our particles in them of
your buffer PHS mu and the ratio of food
and antique acid the the third group is
for the protein you can need some essays
to quantify the rigid VNL the result by
proteins the result chemical agents
gives you the monitoring of your of your
vectors protein and the last one is the
safety of your making the sterna t
advantage the safety of your of your
product in terms of a ratio and a full
and empty capsid you will have of course
in the ad productions in the synthesis
you have different type of
of population the full canticles meaning
that you are in our in your particles
the full vector genome of your interest
the partially fool is a particle that
I've untapped addicted nucleic acid
smaller than the genome of a bee but
also can have some particles from DNA
coming from the process blank as DNA
cetera DNA is a plasmid DNA is a
bacterial DNA and antiparticles does not
have an increased acid at all
so yes different analytical ACH
quantified AG particles to quantify the
full particles and to quantify the total
particles the mix of empty and full
particles to quantify the full particles
you know the method usually commonly use
it's a qpcr Si and give you a
concentration of your vowel genome does
not have any limitations the Amazon it's
an emitter kit which is commercially
available
it gives you a quantification of the
viral capsids but this kit is not
available for all cell types and it's
and this he has this limitation and by
but if you have if you have the keys
available for your filters you can make
a computation and the ratio of the food
and energy by making the difference
between the ELISA and the qpcr method we
can also make measurements of your
quantification of the total amount
occurs by the SDS page for that we need
a high quality of a high purity of your
ad product but you will need also a
licensed under motor and just to make as
to make a smaller curve and to make a
quantification
relation between your product and your
reference pounder some people make a
quantification by spectrophotometry at
260 and to 880 and give you a
relationship between the protein and the
DNA contents and for this method we also
need the reference parameter
by HPLC can make a separation of
Houlihan type capsules
this has been the present in this has
been published by other lamp and for a
v2 and 8.88 but this is so type
dependent dispersion dependence and give
you a low resolution so you can have
from this method not a separation but
mostly a quantification of the total
particles the nanoparticle striking
namely NT heir of the nanoscience it's a
complication of our particle that is the
AV particle it's small it's only our 30
nanometers and the diameters you need to
level the AV particles before to make a
computation the electron microscopy give
you an observation of the vowel particle
as a population and you can make a
codification of the full and
antiparticle that this technique is
difficult to distinguish a partially
full to the empty and full particle so
our challenge was to develop one method
which is independent of the so type
independent of of the Tanjung
independent of the process and can give
you the ratio of the full and empty
particles and we try at the beginning
few years ago almost 10 years ago just
to use a analytical report on
specification to make a complication of
the full and antiparticle and at the
beginning we are basing on whether in
Swedish in 1918 we know that a V you
have C V and light particles for food
and Aunty and in the publications that
presented the food particles which has
an S of net value around 110 and with
and antiparticles are different density
and the H value is 160 50
so from this paper we we try to make to
apply the AUC just to have Navy profile
a profile of the full and antiparticles
so from that go back first to the
principle of the analytical is -
segregation the AUC it's a technical
tools we give you actually a very good a
real-time collection of a senior data
between via 7th and Harlem defense
systems and you can follow the city in
addition of your of your profile during
over the times and this you can pull up
older by absorbance obstacle at the
wavelength to 200 and fill 800
nanometers or by hernán cousins and we
try you can see you can have either a
rotor of the right panel you can have
either a roto of 8 sample or 4 sample so
you can run independently 4 or 8 sample
different of the rotor we try to apply
so we apply the sedimentation velocity
application just to make a separation of
food and antiparticles so from that at
the beginning what you have in yourself
you have at the beginning of the round
if you have an emergence senior
engineers kissed until the bottom and
when you run the sample when we start
the that innovation you try to run and
will form a boundary around over the
times so this boundary will give you a
difference in terms of OD and you will
see a difference between the meniscus
and the bottom you will see the boundary
and you can follow this boundary over
the times either by OD or inter fans and
this boundary motion is the
only on the molecular way and the
molecular shape of your offshore product
you don't need any standard molecule for
calibration this calibration is only
based on the distance the x and the Tom
produce the data scans you will have
like on the right panel you can see that
you will have over the x the scan and
the scan the data scan can be
transformed after like a distribution
profile and for that you use the set
feed software just to make a profile of
your of your data the optical system is
two different one by UV and the other by
inter fans and UV use the scanning speed
it's 1.5 minutes per wavelength store
sells you click at two different
wavelengths and for interference this is
faster the scan of the cell over between
the meniscus and the bottom is 10
seconds per cell the sensitivity it
depends of course of your productivity
and through the ways and advantage of
your products yet southern and for our
interference it does not have any
selectivity but you need you have also a
hypersensitivity of of the senior so for
the wavelength in case of the AV you
will need of course you will choose
where you will have a flat signal so
between 260 and 217 nanometers and in
this French SEL should be between 0 and
1 or T and 1.5 or these this is a
dynamic range of the absorbance in L for
the interference the limited it's as
nearly 20 s in limited we are very right
lunch and to the par 5 milligram per ml
to two milligram per ml of protein the
protein need to be at a minimum in the
research grade and for internal to need
a high quality and it's sprayed
dependent of your buffer
so first of all I would like to show you
some experiment we have been performed
here so just to make a qualification of
the method so for that we try and we
started beginning with a process with a
lot with Navy preparation with as riches
of food and antiparticles and we make
the separation of the food and
antiparticles by cesium chloride reagent
and we collect from the syringe you can
see on in the middle of the slide as a
full bar people to the anti particles
and for an after that we make analytical
for sophistication analysis of
difference propulsion so before I told
you previously that the motion and the
boundary motion with the back of of the
shape of your product and of the
molecular weight of the product and for
that with also control that we do not
have any difference in the shape in demo
shape between the full and anti
particles and we made first of all the
microscopy analysis just to see we do
not have any difference and we also
checked by a dynamic lines covering and
we verified that the the size of the AV
bound people's it's almost a sense and
as you can see here and read this is a
antiparticles and we do this is only for
particles and the diameters of this
empty and full our particle are
transitions and almost the same things
the same size around 26 nanometers so
after that free one and we analyze the
anti particles in blue of the left panel
this is a B and C particles we have a
nice peak at 16 on the right panel in
green
this is a g9 antiparticles where I was
also one single dick around 60 when we
overlay we can see a very nice overlay
of the ABA and AV map meaning that the s
particle it's around 60 164 eyes and the
methodology is a UC cell type in
gentleman's we also run an analysis of
several a lot at different day just to
see the habitability of this method and
for that here you can see the overlay of
five different thoughts five different
proportions and the L value is around 63
to 65 which is almost the same things is
very similar and we have a constant
value we run these both same difference
than independent experiments we have an
averages of the s value 164 more or less
one s so we have a very nice possibility
of the experiment we also look of the
linear range of the of the methods and
for that we take we took one batches and
we run the experiment with that and
dilute in football we route by half and
you die for and we can see that the end
value is about the same and doesn't it's
around 62 to 66 and we have you can look
at the area of the peak is proportional
to the concentration of your product
meaning that we have a very right linear
range a linearity of the scene and
between 0.2 to 1.20 after that to make a
characterization of the antiparticle we
looked at the full particle for that we
take one example the a BJP this our load
has been produced by a triple
transactions in human self beside icism
grind and we make a quality control on
this product and we make a titration of
the VG tighter and we make the total
particle and we have a very nice
correlation between these two sa meaning
that we have only four particles when we
run the AUC you can see one pitch around
102 1 or 2 s and Baidu vo on difference
we have the same thing on only one piece
meaning that we have distance is the
absolute dependence of course of the of
the mass of the DNA on this slide I show
you the overlay of the anti particle a
v8 in blue 89 in green and AVG SP in the
balls
so as value for the anti particles is a
164 and the full particles
it's around 70 to 110 s depending on the
mass of the encapsulated DNA if we go to
the theoretical consideration and to
know to go back to this agenda a portion
what does it mean the as value so as
value is dependent of the mass of health
of your particles is definite of the V
bar of the alpha particles and of the
friction coefficient friction of object
of your production so the L value of the
antiparticles is only depending of the
mass of the catalyst and the rebound of
the capsule the s value of the full
particle is related to the mass of the
solute particle so of the mass of the
capsid and the mass of the DNA so if you
combine these two
relation you can see that the edge value
the L value of the front part particle
is correlated to the to the a defect L
general science to the mass of the DNA
so for that this is the Toyota car and
we demonstrated this by running
different product different price which
has different size of capsulated DNA so
on this side we can see you can I can
show you the sedimentation coefficient
in function of the size of the DNA for a
V 2 88 and 89 in blue red and green you
can see if you do not have any gene size
for all you have the L value around 64
and the L value is increasing and Reena
increasing until 105 for for another CDC
DNA or for 480 nucleotide which is a
maximal size of the Dana insider ad
particle so the L value is proportional
to the size of the tangent and you can
make very nice analysis of Shore
particles so in summary
we can have a characterization of
antiparticles food particles partially
food particles which means in German it
from of 80 depending of course of your
size of malfunction you can also sow
some flavor particles below 60 and you
can see maybe some aggregate if you make
some a dime or something like this over
over 120 s so and the main advantage of
this method
it's a matrices is independent of the
buffer formulation it's independent of
the cell type and definite of the
tangent you can run anything a
difference product difference in one
sense and the limitation needs you need
at least high quality of protease were
crying you need attack we need that at
the minimum five ten to the eleventh VG
per ml and the Willing required for that
it's 400 microliters and the maximum
volume is 400 microliters the minimum
it's one of these microliters now I will
show you some application of the AUC we
have we have used this AC technology
just to analyze self complimentary
elevators versus singles on AV data set
complimentary it's a some DNA some a
lead article which has encapsulated a
double strand DNA instead of single
strand DNA so we have made some double
strand AV denticles
GF is articles ad GFP and we have on the
left panel you can see we make a
characterization of the DNA and you can
see by anchoring gems that we have only
one band at the for 4600 days and on the
left on the right panel
we
made this ad and any desire agency and
you can see one pigs for three different
batches we have mostly one pitch around
64 this is a anti bounty guns which were
possessed around 86% and we have at one
root 3s the full particles fingered the
double strand AV particles which
represent around 7% for another project
we are 489 we compare AV night pollution
to the a double strand to the single
strand so on the SDS page for the value
constable we are to send a profile on in
terms of the VP proteins in them of the
ratio of the ante and the full particles
you can see for the double strand AV you
have almost a 90% of anti particles for
singers on a beam you have 22% of offer
full particles meaning that you have
encapsulated the ankle sedation is lower
the sales complimentary compared to the
second stone so it gives you the AUC
gives you an idea of the floor as a
ratio of the food and ante even for the
singer song and diverse on elevators we
also use this machine the AUC technology
to compare the AV product every data for
this header by a baculovirus system or
triple transaction so on this I will
show you we have two different
processing by a writer and before to
choose between the bacterial virus
system to the transaction system and to
make a prediction at 200 liters we use
these two difference process at a very
small scale at 2 liters and 10 meters
and we look the quality of the product
and the yield of the product the quality
of the process so here you can
the SDS page and on line 1 and 2 itself
or the baculum process on line 3 and 4
is the selection process and you have
almost right easily the same purity of
in both profits in the back you value so
that you can see some extra bond above
vp3
due to the cleavage of ep1 and ep2 but
quality is another thing we look after
the ratio of ante and who capsid by a UC
for 3 different for 3 different batches
of 2 liters you can see you have 127 to
a 31% of full particles for the
transition button we are run 16 to 18 or
full particles and we have or almost the
same process at Twitter and 10 liters
and we have the same amount of full
capsid in both prophecies however we
have up to 20% of intermediate spaces
for the battery various process compared
to the transaction profit so when we
obtained that that profile we look for
to understand and to make a
characterization of what was the
intermediate spices
so for that we make a fractionation by
centrifugation oncidium grind and we
collect all the different factions from
the bottom of the tubes and we make some
fractions a small function around we
make from that around 16 fractions and
from all college education women we we
have performed the sds-page energies the
people say I say and a you see any
disease or static interaction on this
line can see the activities distribution
on the left panel is for the baculovirus
on the right
is a confection process and from the
older fraction from the one it's on from
the bottom of the tube which is an T and
from the 17 which is on the top for the
a heavy particles so you can see the
profile are on the brass it's a
distribution profile for the V people
thing over the fraction and you can seem
like the fractionation confianza a UC
profile that the baculovirus system
denies a bowline capsid of internet
density compared to the transaction
process we have done from the fraction 5
and 14 for the bacterial and from the
fraction 8 to 13 so here this is the
anti particles we can see the ad vector
disposition so here on this slide we
make sure we analyze the distribution of
the author of the vector for
so on this night we make analysis of all
the different not all the different
questions but the fraction which
contains some vp particles fraction l
until 14 and you can see the some
particles each for a v8 question 8 & 9
you can have a 9 speed around 108 and
the full the antiparticle which is in a
race and yellow it's for question at 12
and 13 and we have this the internal
spicy in the protein and the light blue
for the bacteria values sis then we have
more fractions and you can see the L
value for the fraction 5 & 6 we have a
lesser value a 1 1 108 all the
intermediate spicy included between 78
and 19 5s and antiparticles
it's around 64 65 s so The Bachelor very
system generates about and tested of
intermediate density we have also
analogized by to PCR by targeting some
sequence of the function of the genome
DNA and just to analyze what is the
intermediate spicy and in goo by
targeting the RTR sequence and in right
by targeting a specific sequence in the
counting and for the bacterial virus you
can see on the left panel that you can
see you have some hongting some
specifics of food particles in the
fraction piece but you have also some
505 mounted DNA vectors in the under
fraction 7 to 11 and our for the
translation process you do not have the
fragmentation of the genome we also look
for all the contaminant coming from the
process in green from the Daiichi rule
and the Glassman the contents and in
purple for the cellular DNA and you can
see on the graph that almost the this
this impurity are present in the
fragment as a small part a small
fragment small size and in the fraction
7 to 12 as in general spicy and also the
internal spicy for the transflexion
process contain only this type of of
contaminants we have to achieve this
specific contaminant is nonspecific DNA
represents lot less than 0.1% of a
specific vector genome which is very
small amounts so the a you see I told
give you can give you the profile of the
different process and give you for the
bacterial virus we have a fair amount of
the food particles or 127th but we have
frequency data a you see that we have no
intermediate spicy for the bite URLs
compared to the translation process so
the AUC testing allowed there is a
production process in the last slide I
would like to show you the control we
use these technique just to control the
manufacturing process predictions and we
have show example we make this for some
a g2 productions in a Dion sense human
send line and on the Left panel you can
see the SDS page VP profile and are on
the bottom you can see a UC profile of
this project of one of the badges
from with nine different virtues the
eighth value of the food particles is
run 96's more or less run it and who
doesn't around 70 set a 67 percent more
or less as 8% so the AUC technology
method is applied to and shows a lot to
lot consistency in our case we also
check for the vector I can inform you
about the quality of the foil product
during the scallop of your process and
you can see on this slide that we are
run some different batches the same
product but at different scales 50
liters 150 little and 200 liters and 200
liters and the profile the AUC give you
as a the profile of your vectors and it
can give you an information about the
manufacturing process when you scale up
the process and the last example it's
for optimization of the manufacturing
process when you want to compare to one
process to another one
by changing side by side or one step in
our chance I can show you here when we
have one process we have a 1 in black 20
run between 10 to 20 percent of full
particles you change only one parameter
of your process and you can increase
until 40 to 50 persons we use this for a
different type of changing one process
so the agency can give you
monitoring of the product enrichment
during the optimization of the process
state so you can choose in that case the
process even from the deal and also for
the ratio of food and antiparticles and
the process of examining spice in
conclusion the AUC it's a complex
machine in some kind of expensive is
more than 400-thousand a row but the
equipment and data images are not
automatic
Aurora an extensive and proper training
but the AUC is a potent tool to analyze
the aging product profile in the final
product you can make an identification
and quantification food and tea and
other particles you can make the
characterization of soup spicy the
preparation is different molecular
weight you can also compare the first
component original to the singers
functional and you can use this as a
routine based into in from the product
development process and to demonstrate a
lot to Lots consistency in the last line
I would like to earn a Ledge or of
Jeannette on my group biological
developments and specially Flossie rail
and loop route Andrew sorry you run all
the analytical analysis the process
developments and specially Mattias a Ben
will provide all the different batches
Auto maybe and Federico for all the
different interaction with we have and
that's especially that have an alpha
message battle which we start to make
the port of the concept with them thank
you very much for your intention
thank you dr. Levesque for that
informative presentation it's time for
Q&A if you have a question you'd like to
ask please do so now just click on the
green Q&A button at the lower left of
the presentation window type your
question into the box that appears on
your screen and click on the send button
well answer as many of your questions as
we have time for if we are unable to get
to your question dr. Levesque we'll
follow up with you via email after the
presentation let's get started our first
question is did you use some orthogonal
methods like those described in your
presentation to quantify the ratio of
full and empty particles if yes did the
quantification correlate with the
results obtained by AUC thank you for
this question yes we use some different
methods that are presented in the table
and we use the ELISA ELISA kit for 88
particles and we are already a nice
correlation between what we obtain by a
UC and what we obtain between the ratio
of ELISA and the 2pz emitter but as I
said ELISA is not adaptable for all of
the difference a cell tag we also have a
nice coalition for from five times four
by eight for microscopy but this
technique can give you soup estimation
as soon as the mission of the food
particle as you cannot compare it's very
difficult to distinguish between the
partial fuel and the food to the empty
particles so usually the battery fool
it's a usually account like a full Banta
code and you
super pseudo estimates the percent of
the food particles
thank you you perform a you see
technology as a routine test to monitor
the quality of the AAV vector do you
plan to validate this method for a
quality control of cGMP Lots as a
release testing right now we make some
quantification of the method as I
present so we make some repeatability
tyr's to the most excellent activity and
the linear range of the senior for
making a full validation of this method
for quality control of cGMP lot as a
really stating you we should validate it
the software and so far it's really
difficult the software has been
developed by an academic and university
and we don't claim to use this as for
release testing of GMT lot but some I I
heard and some people try to to do this
actually
thank you the next question is are you
using the AUC as an indicating si in the
stability studies yes we use this AUC
for study used to be for showing if we
have any difference form during crisis
conditions if you make a phrase and
present so our examples as the
difference time like three to five times
or if you leave your sample for one
month at the front of our tool so far we
didn't see any degradation of AD
particles we didn't see any difference
that the dimensions associate societies
by some ways of use also with technology
just to as an educated and issued some
different from after 37 degrees great
thank you we'll wrap up with one last
question and that question is how long
does it take to run one effe actually we
have here genital the Beckman Excel one
and for the AV will run at only one
wetlands and we run at the same time Z
and deference and we only can run a free
sample in one one because if you want
seven sample you lose some scanning you
lose some scanning and sensitive data
and you cannot record sensitivity and
everything so it's not so good to run
Morris we can only run one three sample
in one day
I would like to once again thank dr.
Levesque for her presentation do you
have any final comments null Hallman
okay thank you once again dr. Levesque I
would also like to thank lab roots in
Beckman Coulter life sciences for making
today's educational webcast possible
before we go I want to let everyone know
that today's webcast will be available
for on-demand viewing through December
28th 2017 you will receive an email from
lab roots letting you know when this
webcast will be available for replay
please share that announcement with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event that's all for now thank you
for joining us we hope to see you again
soon
goodbye